the joe rogan experience whitney
cummings just texted me shook i can't
believe you guys eating flair fish it's
like
shut up she yelled at me for not voting
she yelled at me for not voting she said
it's
bad for my tell her i said tell her i
said thank you because she's backing up
my filet of fish argument she said it
would be bad for my career if i don't
vote she goes you should do you want to
be the person in 2020 who didn't vote
and i said yes
i mean listen it is what it is you oh
are you you live in california right i
live in california it's not a swing are
you registered to vote there or not i
don't
know my business manager called me
should we register you to vote i said
try to get my license back
i got a suspended license in new york
they're trying to put me in jail
let's focus on that and then we'll get
to voting we'll get the voting in three
or four months
you know uh tim used to sell subprime
mortgage yes okay correct
correct so and i and mike is part of the
project am i living
he was just poked out of his mind and by
a by a an authoritarian government who
took
me and a lot of men from long island who
were trying to help people realize the
american dream
were unfairly painted as criminals
just because we were expanding up
people's uh ability to get credit
sorry sorry i wanted everyone to have a
pool
um yeah so people want to give that
perspective i'm glad you said
and i'm here to give it you started out
selling subprime mortgages
i started out selling cars oh wow and i
as well was also
on many substances oh that's so funny as
i was doing it
that stuff were you good what kind of
cars were you selling um i was selling
chevy's
and are you are you like a good salesman
or no hiker
i'm too nice and i don't give a [ __ ] if
the person buys the car or not i mean
i'm too honest what i was gonna say is i
was probably the number one
um consumer of four loco back when it
was the original
okay well you weren't able to stronger
which is that that's clearly that's
right
it's cocaine in a can are you kidding me
that's not really a joke we were doing
cocaine off our desk
i'd well if i had that i probably would
have done the same thing yeah but for
loco was taken off the shelves because
people were having [ __ ] i said
we were doing lines of blow off a desk
and then taking people's 1040s with
white out and getting them
getting deals done uh jamie's just
motioned to me to get you guys trying to
try to not talk over each other oh [ __ ]
i apologize
kyle's moving into your camera oh oh i
keep doing that i'm sorry let me scoot
this way more
episodes of the joe rogan experience are
now free on spotify
that's right they're free from september
1st to december 1st they're going to be
available everywhere but after december
1st they will only be
available on spotify but they will be
free that includes the video the video
will also be there
it'll also be free that's all we're
asking just go download spotify
much love